in the early 20th century Britain and
Japan had a lot in common they were both
island nations which had poor relations
with their closest neighbors they were
both Naval Imperial Powers who preferred
to fight their Wars in other people's
countries and importantly they both
hated Russia none of these things
changed over the course of the early
20th century yet in 1921 Britain and
Japan's Alliance fell apart which raises
the question why why did the
anglo-japanese alliance fail so for
context back in the late 19th century
Britain was well suspicious of basically
every other major power Germany was a
rising threat Russia was eyeing up India
and Central Asia the USA was asserting
itself across the Americas and France
was France Britain was enjoying a period
of self-imposed geopolitical isolation
but these outside threats could no
longer be ignored as such it was time
for an ally there was always trusty
Portugal but this wasn't the 18th
century anymore and it no longer held
the same Authority Britain at the time
didn't want to side with any of its
European Rivals because the risk of
getting dragged into a major conflict
was too great and the United States was
also happily isolated at this time and
was mostly seen as a threat to Britain's
Caribbean territories thus another Ally
was necessary and only Japan fit the
bill Britain and Japan both had concerns
about Russian expansion into what they
saw as their rightful spheres of
influence both were worried about the
growth of the U.S Navy and both wanted
to force China to buy their stuff as
such the two formed the anglo-japanese
alliance in 1902 they stated that Japan
recognized Britain's Dominion in India
and in return Britain recognized Japan's
interest in Korea and China but in
notably forbid Japan from annexing them
and importantly both agree to support
each other in the event of a war with
two or more powers for Britain this
treaty was seen as more of a statement
of intent that it was no longer isolated
in Japan the treaty was a big deal
because Japanese politicians saw it as
Britain agreeing to help them fight
against Russia and also it was an equal
treaty unlike all of the previous ones
it had to sign so as you'll know Japan
and Russia went to war in 1904 and
Britain didn't get involved now Japan
had hoped that Britain would stay
neutral as a counter to France whom
Russia had an alliance with France
couldn't help because fighting Japan
would mean that Britain would be dragged
into the conflict which France didn't
want Russia was soon unvictorious and
Japan status as a great power was
cemented and as a result Britain was
Keen to renew the alliance but this time
Japan had more leverage as such to
maintain the alliance Britain agreed
that Korea was doomed to annexation and
later on when both Austria-Hungary and
Germany declared war on Britain Japan
was obliged to help which it did seizing
a bunch of German territory in Asia
which Britain was grateful for so why
did the alliance collapse despite it
being so beneficial to both well the
crack started to show at the Versailles
conference as part of the proposed piece
Japan wanted a racial equality clause in
the treaty Britain refused since many
nations within its empire particularly
South Africa and Australia very much
didn't want it this upset the Japanese
because nobody wants an ally that
refuses to accept you as being as human
as they are the treaty wasn't renewed in
1921 because of the deep divisions
within the British Empire about foreign
policy the British government wanted to
renew the alliance as a safeguard
against Soviet French or American
aggression whereas Canada and Australia
saw Japan as an untrustworthy Ally and a
threat to their trade there was also a
push by the United States to get Britain
to ditch the alliance for the potential
of closer relations with Washington and
when the Washington Naval treaty was
concluded the potential of French or
American expansion in the region was
deemed unlikely and so renewing the
alliance wouldn't provide much benefit
to Britain which is why it chose to let
it die and in 1923 both Nations
acknowledged its end thereby forcing
Japan to find new friends I hope you
enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James bisonet Kelly
moneymaker corsha wolf Sky Chappelle
kartowitzker Adam Stalter Alex Schwinn
Jerry lambdin Marcus arsner rod D Martin
a firefly Y and hockey Captain psydog
boogly Wiggly Marvin cassar Winston k
word commune Miss izet Maggie Paskowski
Gustav Swan the mcgwapa Anthony Beckett
Coppertone shewenin spinning three
plates words about books podcast Jim
struenberg Spencer Lightfoot and Charles
the first